these rugged and barren mountains have
become a hub for ISIL sleeper cells
about 250 fighters are estimated to be
hiding here including some foreign
fighters who cross back from Syria they
are strong you know after the after what
happening in the studio too many
firefighters they came back to that
arrogant side we are the mountains of
Karachi near the town of mejor once
under control of ISIL and natural
protective boundary that overlooks a
vast territory claimed by both Iraq and
the Kurds this is the last position of
the Kurdish Peshmerga the defense line
of the Iraqi armies about 5 kilometers
away from here and in between you have
ISIL fighters hiding in cannes at the
bottom of this mountain the mountain
range is ideal territory for sleeper
cells to lay low Kurdish officials say
the fighters have dug a network of
tunnels to connect some of them and are
taking advantage of a security vacuum
coming over Omaha BLM ISIL as a
terrorist organization is not finished
but it's changing its way of operating
it lost territory and now it's organized
in small cells on the move in 2018 there
were 456 attacks and 1242 killed in 2019
there were 238 attacks and 1058
casualties and it continues they happen
mainly in the so-called disputed
territories a vulnerable belt along the
borders of the Kurdish region the Kurds
are against a withdrawal of foreign
troops they have boycotted the
non-binding vote held by Iraq's
Parliament Kanyakumari father
hasari we think this decision was one of
a motion rather than logic it was
hastily taken there are realities on the
ground there are financial and security
issues that have to be taken into
accounts
I don't think pressure from certain
political parties in Iraq all the
killing of Qasem Soleimani and Abu
Maziar Mohandas
were a strong enough reason for the vote
to take place joint operations are key
to prevent ISIL from regrouping here one
carried out in the hungry mountains
cook days before the assassination of
Qasem Soleimani forces under his command
have also played a key role in the fight
against ISIL since Suleiman is death the
fight against ISIL continues but at a
slower pace Kurds and those living in
places like kara Chauhan more fear that
ISIL could take advantage to strengthen
its foothold on the area once again
heard Abdul Hameed
al Jazeera in northern Iraq